ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è esperienze paranormali
parte 2
allora ci siamo ripresi un secondo che
cosa ha detto si può insegnare la base
natura riprendiamo ad ascoltare i
messaggi che ci siamo presi una pausa
che eravamo terrorizzati e non ce la
facevano più sarebbe visto il video la
scorsa settimana cioè capirete benissimo
perché abbiamo avuto bisogno di prendere
fiato
siamo ancora vivi sì che è positivo che
ne avrebbe mai dovuto dire ti prenderei
ad ascoltare il messaggio che invece ci
tocca quindi oppure potremmo non lo so
per giocare a qualcosa riguardo le
esperienze paranormali
non mi è mai capitato niente di strano
però diciamo che tutte le volte che sono
al buio o nella stanza mentre dormo
quando guardo nel buio ciò perché non mi
sempre sempre di vedere la sagoma ogni
volta devo accendere la luce veramente
paura
non mi è mai capitato niente ti spiego
io vorrei fare prendi un faro della
macchina momenti modalità abbagliante e
dormi di giorno rasi sparato negli occhi
che ti brucerà alla rete a quel punto
non vedrai che nulla fa stare meglio
terribile c'è solo accordissimo canterà
vivo cioè sito è ancora vivo un
apparente anziana che sono gli altri
parenti mi avevano detto che faceva cose
poco chiare
arriva a casa anche molto tardi vado a
letto quindi poggia la testa sul cuscino
mi sto per addormentare mi vengono in
mente gli amici dico cosa mi costa ferma
preghiera da quindi faccio stabile
preghierina un'ave maria insomma non
ricordo ecco gli appoggia la testa sul
cuscino il cuscino da diventato tutto
duro mi spazza via da letto terrorizzata
preso scaraventato sto cuscino che era
una pietra si è complicata come avrei
fatto io assolutamente giorno dopo viene
una mia amica lo apre la taglia è dentro
c'era una treccia di capelli e un cuore
rosso di stoffa a detta sua insomma
questa apparente aveva fatto una fattura
di morte ac sua unica dove vivere
io se vedo anche solo un capello vostro
spina prima di un più benedica pelati
sto dormendo ma punta mi sveglio torna
sempre a pancia in giù è certo punto
sento che qualcuno mi sta spirando la
coperta lentamente ice avevo sulle
spalle me la sono ritrovata soprassedere
distinto la la prendo con le mani da
dietro a me la porto sulla schiena dopo
5 secondi mi se ci sia un'altra volta
che mi si entra coperte scivolare via la
riprendo tra me la tengo stretta con le
mani ai sento tirare ma lasciano la
presa a girarmi ma non riuscivo per
giorni non riuscivo a dormire pensando a
questa fatta mi sono dimenticato di
dirti che non mi sono girata non tanto
perché non riuscivo ma perché avevo
paura di cosa previsto quindi non era
una paralisi del sonno diciamo perché
non si sarebbe potuto avere per prendere
la coperta terribile o magari c'è la sua
madre roberta stanotte a tirar qualcuno
che veniva tirato per il vestito cioè
ragazzi vi rendete conto ma vi giuro del
abbiamo raccontato prima qualcuna mio
zio che vede un quadro che si muove che
fa un tic
lo dice alle sue mamme ma perché quel
quadro fantic loro gli dicono e il
dipinto di un trisavolo a quel tic
parenti di cui non faremo il nome
scettici che sono scappati di casa nel
cuore della notte giamaicano e tutto
questo era il barone sanguinario era
all'interno della casa e giamaicano
harry potter penso che quello abbia
influito e il giamaicano chi è scusate
sempre io con il destino ero sicuro non
so per quale motivo una volta stavo
dormendo nella casa tranquilla è stata
in quell'altra ma sento una roba tipo
come una persona velocissima scendeva le
scale a lui o che hanno detto no si
sveglia al giudice americano perché
corrono veloci questa è l'origine dei
soprannomi no la spiegazione che ci
siamo dati e che fosse la nonna il
giamaicano che avete te una signora
gilet
sono foto non so che non sono visto bene
sono visto bene ma che cos'è se capisci
si vede bene siete questo fascino tico
pelata che riguarda il profilo non mi
ricordo neanche mi ricordo niente ma no
oddio ma vita
a me sembra un brutto fotomontaggio ti
prego vai a vedere anche sotto il rigo
che c'è una faccia strana un'aggressione
visione sia io ho visto la faccia
hai fatto un disegno la italia grazie al
paranormale
questa è una foto inquieta sei sempre la
stessa
un giorno in cui era a casa di un mio
amico e stavamo un pochettino su bazooka
costituì in cui puoi parlare con persone
random
in tutto il mondo noi ci eravamo
accertati di essere soli a casa abbiamo
cominciato a parlare con due ragazzi ho
visto che avevamo lo stesso giochino in
un amico ha fatto uno screenshot della
schermata in cui ci mettiamo in porta
con questo giocattolo nemico pubblico a
questa foto su facebook la guardo più
attentamente che belfast rinsch ott
dietro di noi c'era una figura che ci
guardava comunque adesso io allego la
foto vi lascio giudicare siamo confusi
ragazzi ancora meno mi chiamò proprio in
super zoom questa cosa ma secondo voi
che cos'è se non c'era niente è certo
cosa io cario io che ti prego questo
poco poi un occhio alla giuria
la porta della loro stanza mi sa che è
aperta
dio santo bene ci hai fatto la doccia
ufficialmente da letto sarà un quadro di
una bambina che quando mio padre una
piccola 11 nella sua stanza mentre
dormivano lì vicino questa bambina
in questo quadro sopra il letto un certo
punto ho cominciato a sentirla
schiarirsi la voce fatto finta di niente
una notte due notti e tre notti e la
bambina continua avati che ho messo una
mentina sulla cornice del quadro
lei è quella notte non sia più schiarita
la voce e la mentina la mattina dopo non
c'era più ma la cosa peggiore è che mio
padre mi ha raccontato che quando lui
era piccolo che era successa esattamente
la stessa cosa si è messa una mentina
sulla cornice del quadro e la bambina ha
smesso di schiarirsi la voce e si sa
arrivava nuovi volte sento un quadro le
sue mani elementi ne andiamo a dormire
tranquille come tutte le sere ad un
certo punto io in dormiveglia inizio a
sentire un peso ai piedi del letto
questo peso si sposta verso di me dai
piedi sale non chiedermi come ma mi
addormento ad un certo punto e cuore
della notte mi chiama mia sorella
urlando
le chiedo che cosa fosse successo e mi
dice non ti preoccupare accendi la luce
e te lo dico domani mattina arriva la
mattina seguente le chiedo se ne va o
cosa è successo lei mi guarda e mi dice
giada io so se dircelo però ieri notte
si era una ragazza ci nata ai che il
letto ma io ero serena l'anima mia
sorella da te lo dico domani la ragazza
come questa c'è com'è che l'udc o come
ha fatto serena vedere la la ragazza
accor accovacciata ai piedi del letto
l'opera lascia la ragazzina cioè come
funziona neanche io non c'entro il filo
logico avrei evacuato l'edificio
evacuato l'intero
forti che però naturalmente aveva mio
padre conosceremo ottenuto trasferiti a
casa questa nottata a quanto sembra si
diceva forse insensata però non solo
devono infatti nato che pure a poco
prezzo
mia nonna hunter milano il lettone
grande con mio padre che era piccolo
appena hanno spento la luce hanno
cominciato a sentire che le bozze sui
muri come se ci fosse qualcuno dentro
stanze che coltiva onestamente muro
questi batte iniziamo dalla parte più
lontana della stanza e new al pretore
accendevano la luce queste si fermavano
rivolta che loro peggior la luce queste
poste diventavano sempre più vicini ma
che è stata data al comodino in quel
momento
mio nonno e mio padre non sono più
tornati e hanno venduto per la casa oggi
sta casa costa 20 euro
questa casa che verrà costa di piomberà
ciao ciao ospite volevo raccontarvi di
consistenza per la normale che ha fatto
questa mia vita diversi anni fa
praticamente dopo aver fatto e sui
bisogni si è fatta evidente e alla fine
si è accorta che mancava l'asciugamano
per pulirsi allora ad alta voce ha detto
qualcosa tipo cavola due filoni
asciugamano e da parte del bagno che non
era chiusa ma leggermente socchiusa
giovani in fuga mano che poi le prende
al volo
s'asciuga e aceto al bagno per vedere
chi vive lanciato l'asciugamano e scopre
che lei a casa da scuola
io pure vorrebbero bellissima così a
casa mia perché c'è tutto sul corpo per
terra tra fortunata la tua amica
potrebbe care quelli che bussano
prendere moglie nel caso che avevano
lasciato il telecomando sul colosseo
guarda che questa casa invece costerà
più inserviente visibile a ridere notti
means figli le sensazioni di patrioti
ieri spiacenti sono sentito catena rito
cileni quantica di muoversi a quando
aprire gli occhi mi tiro su mi accorgo
di essere sola e inizia a sentire il
primario è fuggito graverà testiera del
letto a tele contro dopo un po non so
bene con degli esteri averli informi la
mattina dopo accolto la storia alla mia
coinquilina il ragazzo nella mia con cui
stanno facendo colazione con me in
mentre la racconto di inquinare gli
occhi e chiedermi quando fosse successo
tutto ciò io gli dico che tutto è
successo intorno alle 3 di notte e lei
mi dice che forse lo stesso orario e il
ragazzo ha ricevuto un messaggio al
telefono e quindi lei e vice di spegnere
la sua migliaia e lui le risponde non ti
preoccupare ci penso al signore e quando
lei riceve quale signore due interditori
direi rifà il signore ti ha indicato
questo ragazzo questo racconto non
c'erano morto sembra il ragazzo in cui
si voglia molla è il signore ma ti
ammazzo sicuramente era una sua taylor
divella il paragone gioco ampio sta
diventando insostenibile
spero di essere ancora intento a
mangiare la mia macabra esperienza
paranormale 45 anni fa sono andata in
campeggio con la mia migliore amica la
sua famiglia e madre la notte dormivano
nel loro camper è praticamente l'ultima
notte mentre stavo dormendo in sveglio
mi giro e davanti a me trovo a fianco al
letto una ragazza i piedi che mi fissa
sveglio la mia amica
tratterò lane si è svegliata mi sono
fatta coraggio che sono rigirata ogni
nuovo e la ragazza è ancora lì no ai
piedi del letto si educa sempre rivolte
verso to me che mi fissava ho dormito
per un mese nell'est e di mio nonno i
all amica mia
la sveglia po più indietro in un film è
nata la stiamo scherzando piacere non so
se a quel punto me la sarei giocata con
cosa vuoi
mi giro mi rigiro e ci sei di nuovo ci
fa pure amicizia vabbè la nel momento
invece voglio vedere cosa vuoi
però faccio prima tira ma che dici mi
sembro tuo fratello maggiore affanno
delle tartarughe ninja perché ho un
guscio di pelle bianca di lancio più
ragazzi siamo reati alla fine di questa
puntata il resto bello non lo voglio
fare il mai più nella vita mai più in
tutta la mia vita io vi ringrazio per
avere condivisi ma soprattutto vi
ringrazio per aver avuto la forza di
sopravvivere ad alcuni di questi
racconti avete tirato fuori roba di
spessore di spessore
ringrazio il seguente ma grazie grazie
anche in realtà enrico giulia che ci
hanno fatto compagnia qui di lato tipo
giuria esigenze delle nostre presenze
che non avete potuto vedere e dire e
scrivere a questo canale siete piaciuto
attivate la notifica per non perdere
nessun video e che dire ci vediamo alla
prossima settimana con un tempo molto
più leggero serie